once we start thinking about the role
that parents and children play in human
evolution one of the things that became
very apparent is that that role was very
different from the prevailing role in
our current culture about parents so in
our current culture there's something
called parenting and that very word that
verb only first appeared in 1958 and if
you look at the Google Ngram it soars up
in the 1970s and that word comes with a
picture and that picture is that what
caregivers do is shape or mold the child
to come out a particular way so your job
as a caregiver is to do a bunch of
things acquire a bunch of expertise that
will lead to a particular kind of child
which will lead to a particular kind of
a ttle and then somehow if you just get
the right expertise you can create a
better child who will create a better at
all now exactly what that better means
is a little unclear I think parents sort
of whisper under their breath better
like better than the kid next door but
anyway there's some picture which i
think of as the carpenter picture of
caregiving which is that you're going to
shape this child into a particular kind
of battle and that picture which goes
with that word parenting really is very
recent it really only developed at the
end of the it really only developed at
the end of the 20th century so that
picture is the picture that's become
prominent in our discussions about
caregiving but it's very very different
from the picture that comes from
thinking about caregiving it in in an
evolutionary context and it's also very
different from the picture that comes
from the studies that we've done in my
lab and others about how children
actually learn another way of thinking
about what caregiving is about is that
rather than having a bunch of procedures
that let us shape a child to come out a
particular way what we do when we're
taking care of children is to provide a
kind of nurturing context an environment
in which lots of variability lots of
different things can happen now if
you're a gardener the way I am one of
the things you know is a gardener is
that nothing ever works out the way that
you originally planned and terrible
things happen
and also marvelous things happen in a
garden that weren't the things that you
were originally thinking about but
there's actually a deeper reason for
that and the deeper reason for that is
that being a gardener is to create a
kind of ecosystem what you really want
to do is create a system with enough
variability and possibility flexibility
robustness so that when the weather
changes or the season changes the garden
as a whole will be able to adjust to
that kind of change and when you think
about the evolutionary function of
childhood that's really what childhood
is about what childhood is about is
providing a period of exploration of
possibility for human beings so that we
can change in the light of changes in
our environment childhood is about
change and caregiving is about providing
safe protected nurturing stable
environment in which that kind of
exploration can take place that's a very
different picture than the parenting
carpentry kind of picture another kind
of metaphor that you could use is you
know think about a monoculture like you
know one of those giant farms where all
they do is grow the same kind of potato
in a way the parenting picture is saying
that we should think about caregiving
taking care of children as being kind of
like creating the very best potato and
we know that that's not a good formula
for robustness we know that that's not a
good formula for dealing with change or
variability so the Gardner picture is
more like creating a meadow where
there's many many different kinds of
flowers many different ways of
developing and that variety and
possibility is what allows the garden to
flourish or the meadow to flourish even
when things change and that's the
evolutionary picture about children and
parents in their relationship and that's
the picture that comes out of our
empirical studies of children's learning
it's very different from the parenting
picture for most of human history the
way that we learned how to be parents
the way that we learned how to take care
of children was by watching the other
people around us so that same
evolutionary development that gave us
this much broader range of caregivers
fathers and Grandpa
and friends and cousins also meant that
when we were growing up ourselves we
were taking care of children from the
time we were very young one of the
things we know is that siblings provide
a lot of caregiving for human beings and
we were watching lots of other people
take care of children the strange thing
that happened at the end of the 20th
century was that as families got smaller
as people got more mobile as people
waited to have children until it an
older and older age we had this
situation sort of unprecedented in human
history where people were having
children who had never taken care of a
child before and that's become even more
true over the past 20 years let's say
the beginning of the 21st century so
that even teenage babysitters have sort
of disappeared from the scene for at
least for middle class and upper upper
middle class children so we have 40 year
olds who have spent a lot of time going
to school and working not spend any time
at all taking care of children so it's
not too surprising that when they sit
down to have a child they think this is
a variety of work this is something that
I can get expertise about the same way
that I got expertise it passing my exams
or I got expertise in achieving my work
goals so this strange sociology of
raising children in the late 20th
century led to this kind of strange and
I think distorted picture of what
caregiving is about and you know of
course there are lots of things that we
evolved to do that we've had to change
and revised changing the way that we
view do things is also part of human
nature but it isn't just that the
parenting model isn't the natural model
it's also just not a very productive
model it hasn't helped parents or
children to thrive it's led to a great
deal of anxiety and guilt on the part of
parents and a great deal of sort of
hovering expectations for children that
really aren't necessary and in fact may
even be counterproductive if we still
want children to innovate and create and
in fact at this particular moment in our
history this post-industrial moment
abilities like imagination creativity
diversity those things are more
important than ever before the irony is
that the way that we evolve
naturally actually seems to be a better
way of encouraging those abilities than
the particular picture that we get from
the schooling of the last hundred years
or so we don't really know very much
about how specific kinds of early
experience shape adult outcomes one of
the things that we know is that early
experience is important because we know
that for instance children who are
impoverished children who are neglected
have all sorts of difficulties and
problems as adults and we can even trace
some of the physiological origins of
that and things like cortisol levels or
or stress so we know that early
experience is important but the kinds of
variance in conscious parenting methods
that middle-class parents stress about
like you know do you go to the stroller
face front or does the stroller face
back or do you start feeding solid food
when the kids are six months old or when
they're a year or when they're three
months old do you co sleep or do you
sleep train children all those things
that becoming sources of enormous stress
as far as we can tell don't make very
much difference in the long run and in
fact again this is part of the
difference between the carpenter on the
gardener model if you think about
caregiving as being a way of encouraging
diversity it kind of makes sense that
you wouldn't see strong correlations
between what specific parents do and
then how those children come out
specifically as adults and that's kind
of the empirical picture so I don't
necessarily think that parents children
who are coming out of this parenting
model are going to be you know have some
terrible deficit that it's going to be
distinct from other children but one
thing that I do think for sure is that
during the process of caregiving the
models making people miserable and sort
of you know children are resilient
children will come out the next
generation of children will come out the
way that they're going to come out but
in the mean time this there's a lot of
unnecessary stress and misery that's
happening both for parents and for
children that is it unnecessary that
isn't actually having the outcomes that
we think and it seems to me plausible
that some features of children
are related to this particular kind of
attitude towards caregiving
so it seems as if at least in Chaddock
totally I don't think we have any data
about this but at least downing totally
it seems that we have this strange thing
with children who are very privileged
have been very well taken care of and
are terribly fearful or terribly afraid
that something bad is going to happen to
them
and that's the kind of combination you
might expect from this kind of a very
controlling parenting model as I say I
don't think we have very clear evidence
for those relationships but at least it
seems anecdotally plausible that that
might happen but I don't think that's
the biggest problem I think the biggest
problem is that life is being made
miserable for parents and for children
in ways that are just not necessary